on january 4th
1976 a fleet of boats
left the coast of maui the goal
was to get to the hawaiian island of
kahool lava
for centuries native hawaiians had
fished and farmed here
and they'd worshipped at its many
religious sites
its original name had been kohei
malamalamu kanaloa
the island had been very sacred and
dedicated to
kanaloa the god of the ocean but
by the time this group of native
hawaiians made the journey to the island
it was a very different story
the u.s military had taken over the
island of kahoa lava
it was just littered with all kinds of
artillery
bombs unexploded bombs nothing growing
it was the worst environmental
damage to land that anybody could ever
experience or view or
feel this is dr amita luli
one of the many native hawaiians on the
boats that day
in 1976. they wanted to take kahoolawe
back
and they were willing to go up against
the most powerful military
in the world what happened next
turned this journey into a movement not
just to reclaim the island but to
reclaim
everything that was taken from native
hawaiians
this is the story of the taking of one
hawaiian island
but before i tell you that story i have
to start with the taking of all of
hawaii
[Music]
more than a thousand years ago the first
polynesian voyagers made it to the
hawaiian archipelago
over time a distinctly hawaiian culture
emerged
fishing and agriculture were common and
a blend
of polynesian language arts and
navigation traditions took
shape along with an intricate social
political
and religious system for centuries
native hawaiians exercised sovereignty
over the islands
by 1810 a monarch united the islands as
one nation
around this time american and european
missionaries arrived
along with businessmen looking to turn
the land into a sugar industry
many missionaries believed hawaiian
religious practices
were a moral wretchedness and so they
began the work of communicating to them
the knowledge of christ when the
missionaries come with their promise of
enlightenment
and wisdom our people lost
contact with who they were over the
course of the next century
this new western christian ideology
slowly replaced the traditions and
culture of many native hawaiians
also known as kanaka maoli or kanaka
the missionaries and businessmen became
advisors to the monarchs
who then suppressed hawaiian language
healing practices
navigation arts and even traditional
forms
of hula soon they set their sights on
privatizing land ownership
and changed the political system too
in 1887 a group led by white businessmen
rewrote the constitution forcibly taking
away
much of the hawaiian monarchy's power
and disenfranchising most native
hawaiian voters
when a new monarch queen liliuo kalani
rose to power she attempted to restore
native hawaiian rights
but in response much of the same group
of wealthy white businessmen
now known as the committee of safety
staged a coup
to overthrow the queen's government in
1893
they illegally took over the government
of hawaii
[Music]
native hawaiians pushed back and started
a movement to reclaim hawaiian
sovereignty
a massive petition drive led to 38 000
signatures
that eventually convinced the u.s
congress to reject the annexation of
hawaii
but it was a short-lived win in 1898
the spanish-american war broke out part
of it was fought in the philippines
and all of a sudden the location of the
hawaiian islands in the pacific
became valuable to the us military
congress quickly passed a resolution and
illegally annexed hawaii
decades later in 1959 hawaii became the
50th state of the us
to have this 50th member is truly a
a unique uh experience but statehood
made many native hawaiian problems worse
the development of resorts and condos
increasingly displaced families
encroached on rural land and exploited
native hawaiians
by the 1970s a new wave of native
hawaiian activists
demanded change and their protests
reignited the movement to reclaim
hawaiian sovereignty
that gave rise to the aloha organization
it stood for aboriginal lands of
hawaiian ancestry
they had a bill for reparations for
native hawaiians
and the congress was not taking it
seriously
aloha came up with an idea they would
occupy
federal land to bring attention to their
cause
the only question was where
caho lavey is the smallest of the major
hawaiian islands
and it sits here in the middle of the
archipelago
some traditional oli or chant spoke of
the importance of the island and
navigation
if you are on kaholawe and you're
observing what the sky
looks like you could see where the
southern cross
sits in the sky in relation to the
northern star
and this was important for training
navigators not so much how to get where
you want to go
but how do you get home archaeological
evidence
also suggests that for centuries
kahoolawe was key
to this kind of celestial navigation and
was the location of several sacred sites
including shrines petroglyphs and
burials
but by 1832 the hawaiian monarchy
started using the island as a penal
colony
then in 1858 the hawaiian government
leased kahoolawe out for ranching
introducing livestock that depleted the
island's soil
in 1941 just after the attack on pearl
harbor
the u.s declared martial law in hawaii
and turned kaholave into a military
bombing range
a few years later when the war ended
hawaiian territorial officials thought
that the island would be returned to
civilian jurisdiction
but instead president eisenhower issued
an executive decree
to extend the u.s use of the island and
then they continued
to train for other arenas in the
asia and the pacific
[Music]
year after year kahoalave was used as a
practice target for more wars
like the korean war and then the vietnam
war
during that period there were targets on
the island that
resembled you know korean vehicles in
korean
uh villages and then jets would come to
practice bombing those targets
the top of the island has been just the
face
of any vegetation it's what we call hard
pan
and about eight feet of the topsoil has
washed away
into the ocean every time there's a big
rain event
it's bleeding out into the ocean in one
series of navy explosions
they simulated an atomic bomb blast and
exploded 500 tons
of tnt and almost
every day in 1970 alone the navy used
the island for bombings or weapons
exercises
those who lived particularly south side
maui
would see the bombing of kahoolabe
regularly houses would shake
it's just like poking a poking a knife
into the spirit of the kanaka every time
the bomb would go off
local residents and politicians began
demanding an
end to the bombings so in january 1976
when aloha was looking for a location to
occupy as a protest
they chose kaho'olave the mismanagement
of land by the navy and the military was
just
so obvious and so it was just something
we kind of like
thought we had to do alluli and other
activists
came together from all over hawaii and
on january 4th
they left for kahoot lava on a fleet of
boats
but there was a problem a leaked press
release
led to the coast guard intercepting them
bringing the risk of arrest
and federal charges one boat with a
lully and eight other protesters on it
snuck past the coast guard and made it
to the island
but the coast guard wasn't far behind
we saw them coming with their megaphones
and
telling us that we needed to board the
coast guard cutter
and get taken back to maui myself and
one of the organizers from maui walter
riddy
decided we didn't come to koh lavi just
to kind of get back
with the coast guard as the coast guard
caught up with the group on the shore
illumi and walter riddy broke away and
went deeper into the island
there were no trails to follow and the
paths were rough
but slowly they made their way up to the
peak of the island
then once you're on the top just knowing
that this
island was almost central in our
archipelago
that it must have been something real
special but then
you see the devastation for two days
alluli and riddy hid out on the island
the island was muddy was red
there was just old trucks that were
lined up to be
caravans and these are the targets the
whole island was littered
with targets on day three federal
marshals
found a lully and ready arrested them
and flew them off the island
we've just been able to kind of be
lifted up on a helicopter and seeing
more damage
and feeling more passionate about we got
to do something
it was like the land was calling to me
pleading crying asking us
to do something we decided to come over
and pay a visit to
to the governor and a peer visit to you
also inspired by what they saw
the activists formed a new group protect
kahoolawe
ohana to focus specifically on caring
for the island
at the core of their work was the
concept of aloha aina
aloha aina in its simplest form is just
to love the land
but for us aloha aina also has a deep
political meaning
and that it means love of your nation
the organizing for helped spark a
greater movement for hawaiian rights
in what became known as the hawaiian
renaissance
congress and american people need to
know we're not just happy natives
dancing the hula for the tourists and
playing our ukulele and that
we have serious problems with so many of
our
people incarcerated so many of our
families having to rely upon welfare for
their
subsistence and very serious health
problems
activists across hawaii were pushing for
the revival of hawaiian culture
language and ethnic studies education
along with land and water rights for
residents
if we can give mother nature back to
call of duty fight we gotta go fight
as for the island of kahoolawe a
charismatic activist
named george helm stepped up to lead the
fight to put an end to the bombings
and for months the group organized
further occupations of the island
and if all of us can go over there and
touch it
we all come together so that began a
movement
there must have been like maybe 30 other
arrests
individuals there was jail time the navy
didn't know how to handle this
i didn't know how to control the arrests
the movement was picking up
but in 1977 tragedy struck
two activists hemo mitchell and leader
george helm were lost at sea on the way
back from cahoa lava
george helm after he disappeared we
didn't know
why he left how he left and who was
responsible for it
we had to reorganize our movement
we all felt that we had to make a
commitment
to make his life worthwhile that the
loss would not be in vain
prior to his disappearance helm had
spearheaded something important
a class-action civil suit against the
navy
the suit claimed the navy was in
violation of environmental protection
laws
and the national historic preservation
act
there are cultural sites that are on the
island
and the navy was not doing its duty to
protect them
in 1980 the navy and protect kahoolaway
ohana
entered into a consent decree the navy
would have to start cleaning up the
island
and give activists partial access too
one of the first things activists did
was revive the makahiki ceremony
a religious celebration that had been
suppressed for two hundred years
the most important thing that the
protect lavi ohana has probably
accomplished
is reviving our connection as native
hawaiians to
our kua our natural elements and and
calling our
our deities back into our lives and and
reviving our soul as a people
after another decade of continued
pressure in 1990
president george h.w bush ordered the
complete halt
to bombing practices on the island
congress also ordered the return of the
island to hawaii
and hawaii's state legislature banned
any future commercial activity on the
island
fourteen years after the first landing
on pahoa lava
a grassroots movement was able to take
on the u.s navy
and when
[Music]
today the restoration of kahoot lava is
ongoing
the u.s government still hasn't gotten
rid of all the bomb fragments and
unexploded ordnance
but with the help of protect kaho'olave
ohana and a state reserve commission
the island is slowly healing the closer
you get
you see the island is getting green it's
important
that we have places like kahoolawe to
sort of serve as these
key puka as we call them or little
circles
little areas where where life
regenerates
to really re-engage with environment and
earth and see
the importance of aloha aina really
kahoolawe is now a symbol of hope
and for native hawaiians who continue to
fight for sovereignty
reclaiming kahool lava is a step
towards reclaiming all of hawaii
kolavi is a motto of what can be done
on other islands and other communities
the only
disappointing frustration is that i'm
not going to be around
for the next generation kahool lava is
the
hope that brings us deliverance from
our colonized past to
who we are and who we will be in the
future
[Music]
you